you know when i look back over some of
the places i've flown over the years i
could easily tell you where i went how
long the flight was and even how much it
cost but if i'm being honest i'd
struggle to tell you how much pollution
those journeys emitted however recently
i've been seeing adverts like this the
world's first carbon neutral airline
100 green newer greener better
now the international air transport
association oriata which is a group of
almost 300 airlines has set those
companies a target net carbon zero by
2050. we have 29 years of work to do
don't don't worry about that it's a big
challenge one that iata forecast could
cost two trillion dollars that's because
the industry has thrived on fossil fuels
and it's yet to find anything as
efficient or as economical as kerosene
in 2019 it pumped out around 1 billion
metric tons of co2 that's roughly 2.8
of global co2 emissions from burning
fossil fuels so ayata has proposed some
methods for airlines to try and hit that
net zero target but the keyword there is
net more on that later the target is
aspirational and it's hugely ambitious
so in the future will i ever be able to
say that i'm flying without polluting
well to find out more i called ayata and
i spoke to our resident aviation
reporter doug cameron let's dive
in the largest part of iata's plan is
sustainable aviation fuels or saf the
association says that by 2050 these
fuels could account for 65 of emission
reductions think of sustainable aviation
fuel a bit like the ethanol that is
blended into uh
into gas in the us they're made from
things like plants cooking oil or even
some of the waste from your home and
their emissions are calculated by
looking at the total life cycle of the
fuel from creation to end use and not
just what comes out of the tailpipe but
the problem is it's expensive to make
unless you make a lot of it what the
airlines want the government to do is to
start subsidising the refineries so it
doesn't cost as much
right now iata says there's only enough
capacity to produce around 100 million
liters of it a year but to hit those net
zero targets iota forecasts that by 2050
the industry will need around about 450
billion liters so really is a big number
and to give you context that's about one
and a half times all of the jet fuel
used in 2019
so another option that the industry is
exploring is hydrogen which is also yet
to achieve commercial scale i actually
did a whole video on airbus's plans for
hydrogen planes and i've left a link to
that below check it out once you've
finished watching this one hydrogen also
has a few hurdles to overcome we need to
make the hydrogen that's complex so that
requires a huge expansion of renewable
electricity capacity the fuel also takes
up more space than kerosene just check
out how much extra space it takes on
airbus's proposed hydrogen planes
and according to ayata even if every
single short-haul aircraft was replaced
with a hydrogen or an electric plane it
would still only account for around a
quarter of emissions so if the industry
can't fully eliminate its co2 emissions
maybe you can try and bury some of them
instead you're basically finding a a big
mine or an old well in texas and uh
shoving that carbon dioxide down
underground iata said that it forecasts
that carbon capture will account for 11
of emissions reduction by 2015 but it's
embryonic in its
technology
uh development
we think it will play a role
so you may have noticed a bit of a theme
here and that's that right now none of
the methods that i've mentioned are at a
scale where they could hit those
emissions targets
but there is one measure that the
industry is using today and that's
carbon offsetting it works by airlines
measuring how much co2 they emit and
then simply buying credits towards
projects that in theory counter that co2
production however these have not really
had huge takeout a lot of a few big
airlines i've got them uh
people are very suspicious about
following through did they actually
plant that tree is my name on it so
that's a that's a tricky one in the near
term ayata says the offsetting will
account for a whopping 97 of emission
reduction but that's a number that they
hope will go down in the future in order
for that to happen though many of these
other measures that we've just discussed
would have to become a commercial
reality but even with all those measures
in place it still seems like fossil
fuels will have some role in my future
flights so if we're going to keep flying
we may have to come to terms with the
fact that the aviation industry may
never hit true carbon zero
hey each one of the measures that i've
discussed in this video could be its own
video so which ones are you interested
in let me know in the comments below and
as always if you're interested in the
future of how we might be getting from a
to b then don't forget to subscribe see
you soon
[Music]